come on my girl amazing how are you how
are the nerves you good I'm good
yeah a little bird told me that we may
see you in Alek on stage together
tonight is that happening we may yeah
and then they might get a little crazy
oh boy
in character in the character of
ourselves ha ha ha
now did you run any of the material past
your hubby he's a pretty funny guy too
he's not gonna be here tonight he's in
the UK shooting a television show for FX
so unfortunately he's not here by the
way he had one of my favorite movies of
the year in hearts beat loud and I'm it
was really one of the sweetest most
wonderful movies that I had seen them
yeah and Will & Grace is back Thursday
[Music]
the 31st Lee it's really actually a big
episode for my character Karen I get to
actually
for real in the episode it seemed kind
of as myself so well we know you have an
album out I've heard it I had it and you
you can sing missing any singing tonight
you said my character Karen as if we all
don't know like we you don't need to say
your character I know you're like line I
don't we will although you could play
all three of them if you really try can
I ask you about the fashion because I
see these Chanel earrings and I'm kind
of losing my mind those look vintage I'm
wearing two different dresses in the
show that I bought online so I would
like to thank you Nana port a and
matches fashion I was gonna ask you cuz
you brought the Carolina Herrera online
as well go out and try to get dresses
and then they say no and then you're
like okay Artie - wait right that going
to have a dress made so I don't I also
rented this so this is real you know but
do you sell it after do you keep it for
your archives no not only do I not sell
I've got I'll wear this like five more
times but that's why that's why I love
you though that's real
Oh what time just make it a minute
[Music]